dahmane sayah
ce n'est pas le printemps qu'agatha
avait imaginé il avait loué elle devait
finir ses équipes à 21 ans elle un
prophète et elle découvre pour la
première fois de sa vie ce que c'est
d'être laid
c'est son père qui l'a envoyé à tibi il
est un journaliste indépendant moscou et
critique du kremlin et de la guerre un
habitué de l'intimidation mais les
menaces qu'il a reçues du service de
renseignement il ya un mois et est
explicite et terrifiante
3 leur ford
f s
la georgie est devenue un pays refuge
pour des dizaines de milliers de russes
un des rares pays où ils peuvent
s'installer un an sans visa mais pas
sans jugement est de plus en plus de
georges et ont signé cette pétition qui
réclame un régime de visas pour faire le
trou pour un peuple encore traumatisée
par l'agression et par l'occupation
russe en géorgie en 2008 le malaise se
comprend
dans les hauteurs de la ville nous
croisons tilia il passe des heures à
regarder les passants et nous pointe
avec mépris l'immeuble juste en face ou
plusieurs ruches louent des appartements
j'aime les gens mais les russes ce qui
arrive ici on peut jamais savoir ce
qu'ils ont dans le coeur elle ignore
qu'en réalité ces jeunes exilés des
tests vladimir poutine autant qu'elle
sinon plus agatha est une des locataires
de l'immeuble il ya aussi eu jane fiodor
romane et d'autres rues ce que nous
pouvons identifier car chaque étage
chaque appartement à son histoire de
répression
son mari est connu des autorités
une activiste de longue date répugné par
la guerre mais il dit que c'est la
propagande imposé à ses enfants à
l'école qui a précipité leur départ
nous avons accepté de protéger leur
identité car même à l'étranger la parité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le droit de manifester comme le font les
charges et sans être pourchassés
explique fiodor qu'il a souvent été à
saint pétersbourg quand la guerre a
éclaté et c'est le risque bien réel
d'être conscrits qui l'a convaincu
s'enfuir en georgie
ingénieur de formation il travaillait
pour rosatom l'agencé russe d'énergie
atomique aujourd'hui il est concierge de
l'immeuble et aide ses compatriotes à
s'installer dans un pays où ils ne sont
pas toujours les bienvenus des banques
exigent même que les russes confirment
leur opposition à la guerre pour ouvrir
un conte just
[Musique]
on voit beaucoup ça en charge étant
donné que énormément de risques sans
s'installer ici il est écrit
la russie est un agresseur poutine et le
diable si vous n'êtes pas d'accord vous
n'entrez pas c'est devenu la norme car
tout le monde ici affiche son soutien
l'ukraine si bien qu agatha a dit
qu'elle a parfois honte de parler russe
en public
nous en tant que russe il porte souvent
le dieu de ceux qui soutiennent encore
le régime à la maison cet activiste dit
que c'est le cas de sa mère et sa lutte
puis il y à romane le plus jeune des
locataires russe en exil il se promène
toujours en ville avec son drapeau anti
guerre pour afficher ses couleurs il ya
déjà été battus par la police en russie
à 18 ans il a fait une croix sur son
pays pour fuir le seul président qui l'a
connu
il romane tenait absolument à le dire de
vive voix et en personne à sa voisine de
quartier de sillery
pour qu'elle comprenne que les russes ne
sont pas tous poutine
lui aussi ont été trahis